the puny little giraffe weevil may not
look like he can put up much of a fight
against a big rival but that doesn't
keep him from getting the girl the
little guy just has to be a bit
stealthier to make sure he gets a chance
to meet Christina painting of the
University of Auckland studies to RAF
weevils and the forests of New Zealand
she describes how they got their name
the mail looks like a long sort of
giraffe and his appearance because he's
got this really elongated part of his
head so the head is the rostrum which is
the really really long part of his snout
whereas he is actually an extension of
its head and he's got his jaws right at
the very very tip of there so it almost
acts as like a lever because he can use
his jaws but she's right the very tip to
grab hold of an opponent's male and then
he can move his rush trim or the
extension of his head up and down until
he's able to get a good grip and throw
the other male off females don't use
their snouts this way they use the tip
of their snouts like drill bits to make
holes they lay an egg in each hole and
they keep drilling the treat even while
the males are fighting each other
painting has watched countless fights
between male giraffe labels what she
found is that small males can actually
creep along and slip themselves between
another male and a female that's so that
the small male and take his turn with
the female you can see that the small
amount of slowly wedges and South in
between the mating male and the female
which disturbs the male that was mating
so the mating male then gets off and
tries to pull off that small male to
stay in place the small amount can tuck
himself around the side of the female
that way even if he is detected he
doesn't get pulled off at least but in
this case the part of what makes a
sneaker male a true creep is that he can
slip in and move so slowly that he
essentially undetectable by a bigger man
well I guess his eyesight's not very
good and he can't I mean he's pretty big
compared to that tiny male so he I guess
he can't he maybe just doesn't detect
that something's going on or he thinks
it's the female moving I'm not sure what
is clear is that big giraffe weevil
spite vigorously as painting describes
the biggest player on that screen so
then the center of the shop is a male a
large male who's trying to fight for
access to the female she's at the very
bottom of a pile so we see now the male
that was mating with her getting picked
up the big male so he waves that little
male up and down until he gets a good I
guess
he's shot and then throws him off the
tree and now the bigger male is back
approaching that female the female
doesn't seem to be interested or using
those fights in any way to sort of
assess male quality for her she doesn't
appear to be making any or not any
choice in her her mating partner is she
possibly might be making choice after
they've made it in terms of what sperm
she chooses to fertilize her eggs but we
don't know that yet but certainly there
doesn't appear to be any courtship and
no role by the female and choosing a
mate so it's entirely sort of the sexual
selection on on that long snout as as
definitely seems to be driven by
male-male competition rather than female
choice for a big male and in all this
competition smaller males don't just
sneak about they choose when to sneak
and when to fight and they will grapple
with another male but typically only if
it's a male of roughly the same size
this is a Greco so they've matched
they're sort of the body side to side of
each other and the aim of the game is to
try and use your jaws to grab hold of
one of the opponent's legs or they're
even there in TNA and to try and
basically flick them off the tree the
fact that small mouths can also fight as
well as sneak I do really want to hammer
home that that's a real
part of their behavior because
sneaking's not that unique among animals
but I think what's really cool and rare
is that when a the sneaking or the
subordinate males can also have a very
flexible strategy that's probably why
they're at least gaining as many mating
opportunities as those larger males it's
good to know the little guys don't
always finish last